you should 100% care of the Trident with
you now everybody go I'm a little
surprised you're not like sitting on
your throne with it beside you right now
this must be the wildest ride like
something I really appreciate about you
on social medias that you always share
like the process and how excited you are
about your projects and about things
with your fans
does this feel now like are you kind of
giddy about this because this is wild
this is amazing yeah everything that I'm
doing in my career right now is is what
I've you know hope for whether it be a
small independent film to you know
you're in Canada frontiers very very
dear to me ain't nobody that we're gonna
release the making of that whole process
Aquaman I wanted fans to experience what
I'm going through and it's just this
world tour that I've never been on
anything this size before so it's just
kind of fun be old and also you know
it's giving me a you know a box to shout
from on environmental issues that you
know with Aquaman hopefully some really
great things that I can do for the
environment and yeah equals awareness
and you the fan base that's just really
support you and love you they've been
around for so long and it's kind of nice
that they can go on these journeys and I
also just getting misrepresented I think
sometimes you do press and they want to
release like some little piece that
you're like that's not with our whole no
one really wants to intimate side of it
I think there's there's one we're gonna
release tomorrow it's pretty funny so
they have like in a bathtub when you're
in an audience full of people who I mean
I don't know if you stuck around for the
screen last night but when you appear
for the first time in the submarine and
we saw this in the trailer tip and you
turn around and you're like permission
to come aboard put everybody under
audience just lose it they listen they
lose their mind when they see you for
the first time but like what's your
reaction to them reacting to you on
screen it's crazy I haven't seen anyone
react to it on screen yet I haven't
watched it and I'm gonna wait to see it
with my babies oh nice yeah so it'd be
made in two weeks it in LA so not there
yet but yeah I'm excited
I've never had this positive response to
anything I've done so it's kind of a
very surreal to do not know anything
that's
I've seen it that's amazing like
everybody else is all the other actors
talking about how amazing it is to see
like the world of Atlantis on the screen
and you're still kind of in the dark
about it yeah which is uh yeah it is but
I just it's it's once-in-a-lifetime
chance to experience it with my children
I think which I think this is a such a
family movie and you know what it's
gonna be like I could imagine if I was
eight years old and uh I'm being home
you don't have Hawaiian sea and half
Hawaiian superhero up there or being
just half brown yeah going like oh my
goodness and see with my kids and so I
just want to kind of hold out for that
moment well that's cool like you're I
mean you're even changing the way he's
represented the characters representing
the comic books - I feel like we will
we'll get to the part where he will
became but it's a long few frames of
this movie he's gonna become the king of
Atlantis which in Aquaman he's always
the king of Atlantis this is all about
that reluctant ain't no to the hero's
journey - that's the part that interests
me is his flaws and being human but it's
also his powers as being half human and
in the empathy and humanity that he has
so it's it's the making of to get to the
king so I mean if it continues on and
people like it it's gonna be he's gonna
I mean now he controls the ocean it's
yeah it's a different deer than you know
I mean
I want to see I just want to see him
roll to the bar with a trident
jusers tried everybody Hey
you